I think of the human race says someone
who became separated from their mother's
hand in a department store for 15,000
years now we've been running from
department to department you know is it
tennis rackets is it bicycles is it
sleds what is it should it chew it
listen no no we have to return to an
authentic psychedelic shamanism that is
rooted in our experience if we empower
our experience we will cease to be the
easily manipulated democratic math
system with Democratic masters do you
know what kind of an insult that is to
you would mean to be called the
Democratic masses if we empower
ourselves and become reacquainted with
the authentic dimension within us then
we won't put up with this crap anymore
this is what happened in the 1960s would
it put up with it anymore and they
poured into the streets and raised holy
hell scared everybody to death
why wouldn't they put up with it anymore
because they saw how shoddy chintzy and
not together it is we've been sold a pig
in a poke it's not worth having these
things don't make us happy they don't
bring
wisdom they don't give us yeah it's an
infantile insulting ridiculous society
except that it's holding a gun to the
head of every living thing on this
planet
[Music]